how's it going Bryce my name is
PewDiePie today we're going to check out
some AI stuff I'm a bit late on this
train I'm sure you've noticed AI has
made tremendous leaps that we're today
going to explore in fact this entire
video intro
was made by an AI just kidding it didn't
work
fully you've seen this I'm sure uh you
can type in whatever you want to see
that is not a respective they look they
look real that looks like beans
that is what how did we come from
beer Bean that's not a bad slogan for
you being Benin
this looks like really bad fan art I
think you can do better let's just see
what we get what does AI PewDiePie look
like he's going to take over this
channel eventually so we might as well
get acquainted why do I get bad fan art
no no offense too
up
wow AI is going to take over this is
crazy maybe I should specify realistic
what what
am I slurping on
I mean
hey
all right V another feature they have is
called out painting I think this is the
greatest one because you get a picture
and then you can delete part and the AI
will fill it in uh for example why don't
we go to my Instagram we'll take this
photo of me and Momo very cute We'll add
that
[Laughter]
here's what I wanted today I wanted to
delete Momo and then generate and see
what it comes up with
[Laughter]
I mean
good actually
I type jacksept again
all right I'll just type I'll type pen
see what we get
Mama
it's Kermit kind of I don't even know
what if we take this photo of me and
Mars yet alt Universe AI March yeah what
did we get
foreign
did a good job in the background
I'm not pleased or if you just type Mars
here
let's try pug I can only imagine
nightmares yep I don't know
it's pretty good actually yeah I'm okay
with that one that one's fine okay what
if we take this it only has half my head
so I guess it will fill it in
it looks like looks like some early
balding is going on here I don't know
why you try to tell me hey
fine
let's fix that
uh what should I hold energy drink there
better be another G fuel in there that's
the only correct answer code PewDiePie
that is that
wrong
forbidden Russian drink his face well
let's just see what he gets wants to put
there
because
p
what
no no
delete it I'm suing you AA
all right there should be a better one
I'm I'm ominous y'all my favorite
YouTube plank thank you so I can edit
this one
foreign
missed my mouth entirely well done okay
here we have half my face anyway let's
see how AI what I will do with this
why does random text appear I don't get
it at least I got a face on this one
free with friends
what is a subliminal message
Sick Beard though oh I need a mustache
holy P Prime P Prime but all right I got
shot GPT working finally let me just try
something first
there we go
hi everyone and welcome back to our
Channel today we're talking about online
privacy and security which is a critical
issue in today's digital world
as you all know the internet can be a
dangerous place it's important to have
protection when browsing online that's
why we're so excited to have nordvpn as
our sponsor for this segment logo with
animation into music
nordvpn is the world's leading VPN
provider a so I've cut to nordvpn
animation with information about their
features if you're ready to take your
online privacy and security to the next
level then head over to nordvpn.com and
get started today trust us you won't
regret it uh play the outro music and
animation inside and a call out to
action to visit nordvpn.com that was
actually pretty good all that
aside I I love using VPN you guys know
nordvpn and if you switch the end with
the p I'm not going to say anything else
mirror VPN is also celebrating their
11th birthday I don't know why I did it
too and if you sign up with the link in
the description you have a chance to win
one additional year for free
but everyone that signs up will get a
huge discount on a two-year deal that's
where it came in plus additional gift
if you sign up during this special time
you can get an additional four months
for free that's not vpn.com PewDiePie
click the link say thanks all right
let's keep trying oh this is perfect I
have glorious legs super strong super
long let's see how AI handles legs yeah
yeah yeah
yes finally something useful you mean
long luscious links
yeah boy
that's what I'm talking about thank you
Eric killing the game
nailed it first try just try again just
to be safe I feel like it's not accurate
really what
no I asked for muscular legs not
[Music]
need to help AI like give him more space
to work with what why are they so dainty
stop it
yo am I wearing Yeezys or a bag of
plastic bags you know what fine well I
hope that squashes my leg length debate
at last that reminds me of that Meme I
want to see how they interpret this
because everyone was like oh he's he
doesn't have any legs I'm curious let's
try this
no no that's not what I asked for
although that looks kind of sick not
gonna lie no table I gave them too much
to work with there we go
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
let's try again it's cool they can tell
we're sitting damn it they keep giving
them good lengths even though I'm trying
to give them baby legs but I mine are
still better
why why did it not give it to me
AI is on to something though Gina though
Gina why did I not get legs that is so
I'm done off
garbage shoes again I'm not poor stop it
although they do kind of look like my
shoes I take it back okay let's see what
AI thinks my new G fuel drink should be
no stop it
we're entering the danger zone now
is
hippies oh it's hashtag IPS
I'm wearing a diaper
you know what fine what happens if I
type the best YouTuber God I hate
YouTubers this is how AI sees it no no
yogurt what if I do like text proms like
a motivational quote
oh no eat Diffie New York at your date
did delete it
thank you well you truly know how to
speak to people picking outing up
[Music]
all right loopy died Snowbird flop and
take more you're facting slavat the gay
fat for turtle thank you thank you so
much
oh God I'm getting into it now they
can't do this I'll just get the fan art
I swear
is that all right sure
this is gay I just want to know wow
you know they took some like bad Brony
Fine Art and was like yeah we'll make PC
sorry fan art fans you're useless now I
can just look at this
and be satisfied another thing I wanted
to try out is text-to-speech it's
supposed to mimic other voices Naruto
One Piece Yu-Gi-Oh Joey the greatest
voice actor give me that beautiful New
York accent my ass Huss
that was pretty good my ass hurts
my jewelry wheeler my eggs hurts my ass
Hearts oh
this is not bad damn voice actor so you
better be scared because you're about to
be replaced Naruto what do we got Sasuke
okay
I'm 12 dude I'm sorry I'm sorry
not until you're such a vacuum
no
I'm actually 12. thank you what else do
we got here YouTubers do we have it yes
all right let's try it how's it going
bros it's me PewDiePie
oh
how's it going bros it's me PewDiePie
pretty good
let's clean it up a bit
how is it going bros it's me PewDiePie
ah come on
come on I guess I can't be replaced by
AI just yay all right we got me do we
have that Irish Mane yes we do come on
Chop Chop AI top of the morning ladies
damn the top of the morning is not bad
it does that that
good morning ladies I'm jackseptic I'm a
horse shoe time reporting Camp he's so
much better I can't
[Music]
zero confidence jacksepticeye
what happened let's try it simple
perfect so much better
that's right jacksepticey is so much
better you're right what's up everybody
it's female or kaplarn
pretty spot-on I'd say let's try this my
nipples are distance
now squeeze my nipples
oh
it's okay all right what's up it's
critical insert nipple jute Here YouTube
here today's drama was crazy anyway see
here
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay I'm out
that should be difficult
that's the most well articulated I've
ever heard him incredible wow all right
I found one that doesn't use tick time
[Music]
foreign
I should do the trick
[Laughter]
[Music]
is Anime titties too much to ask for and
he may anime
no I'm doing a video is it because of my
beard
this is a different photo that isn't
even like
I've seen people do like they cover that
one of their eyes maybe I'll do that and
see what the effects are
now we know if it's legit
oh
[Music]
me an idea yeah
2G fuels
there we go dominant post what what
don't you
okay here we go at last
excuse me why is there the c word on me
give me one more chance anime filter
it's just me and my G fuel what can go
wrong
laughs
all right
where did you get Christmas from that
photo AI anyway AI is dumb it's sales
from artist which is bad don't steal and
I don't like it not one big smash like
subscribe if you feel the same or if
you're indifferent or if you strongly
agree see you next time and remember